thank you everyone for coming and it was
the first talk of the day so I'm
surprised anyone came especially if we
talk about insects so I really
appreciate that
and it's date of visual a visualization
week Columbia and so being the first
talk of the day I'm gonna discuss a
branch of biology where that deals with
single data points or small collections
of data points and often these data
points that represent the most amount of
data you can get and so the name of the
game is to try and really do justice to
these single data points and this branch
of biology is collections based research
so in museums around the world there are
hundreds of millions of specimens of all
kinds of organisms and minerals and
different objects from the natural world
and they've all been given names and
it's this process of naming these
objects just to taxonomy which forms the
foundation at least in biological
sciences for many other sub disciplines
within this field and so finding these
organisms in nature collecting them
giving them names putting them in these
museums which are then repositories for
biologic biological objects is extremely
important and often in in biology all
you can find is a single member of a
species or just a few representatives of
their species and so for that species to
become something that has a genuine
value in biology you have to describe it
you have to name it you have to put a
label on it a holo type label have to
store it in the museum and make that
information available
to other people usually in the form of a
publication okay so what I'm going to
discuss today is how the role of imaging
in this process of taxonomy and species
description and the expansion of
biological knowledge over the past two
to three hundred years okay so there are
about 1.7 million described species of
organisms so these are organisms that
people have found collected names
described put into museums and this
represents depends who you ask really
may be between 50% and perhaps 10% of
the total number of organisms there are
on earth and most organisms one in every
four living things is about 400,000
species of them are beetles which are my
favorite group of organisms now to get
to 400,000 species for the past 250
years or so people have been collecting
these things throughout the world are
doing exactly what I've just told you
putting pins through them giving them
names right species description
sometimes doing an illustration or
photograph of them putting them into
museums and that description and the
information about where these things at
deposited is of use to entomologist
throughout the world and this branch of
biology that does this is called taxon
and is the naming and describing of new
species new general new higher taxes so
things like families and orders and
phyla okay and it's not just stamp
collecting
taxonomy forms the basis of all biology
because it's only through describing
species that you can partition up the
natural world into these distinct living
entities and this is really the kind of
foundation for all of these other fields
so for example an evolution in biology
you didn't
we're species boundaries lie it wouldn't
be able to explore the evolutionary
relationships between species we
wouldn't be able to build phylogenetic
evolutionary trees to see how these
species have evolved and how they're
related to each other we wouldn't
understand the process of speciation
whereby one species splits into two and
we wouldn't really understand what we
the fossil record and the evolutionary
history of life on Earth
likewise taxonomy forms the basis for
ecology it's only through knowing what
species are out there that we can study
the interactions of these different
populations and communities that form
ecosystems and of course organismal
biology anatomy embryology in
neurobiology behavior we have to know
what species were dealing with to really
make comparisons between species and of
course all of these disciplines are
related to each other in this rich field
of biology you where we are where the
goal is to understand the evolution and
functions of different organisms and
their structures which components of
them and of course in this day in age
where we're just destroying the
environment
rampantly taxonomy and collections based
research and accumulation of specimens
in museum it has an additional important
role in documenting all of this life on
Earth before it goes extinct so many
specimens and museums now probably
represent species should no longer found
in nature so taxonomy defines the
organisms in the natural world that are
living now and organisms which have
lived in the past it's okay so you can't
just go out find what you think is a new
species give it name it after your
mother and then say oh this is mine new
species named after my Marten there are
specific rules involved in describing
and use new species and making it an
available name and there's a code with
thank you very much great appointment
tiny it's not a heresy but it's a dart
nonetheless okay so when it comes to
describing a new species there's a code
to set rules you have to adhere to which
is specified by the international code
of zoological nomenclature and this is
an enormous to complicated long list
that you have to adhere to when you
write find it what you think is a new
species okay but the major
a component of describing a new species
is publishing the name more than the
main cultural act okay so you dream up
the name you have to publish it in a
journal and you also have to accompany
it with a description or definition that
states and words characters that are
purported to differentiate the taxon
from other species so you need to back
up your claim that this is a new species
with distinguishing characteristics and
the guy who really got the ball rolling
in taxonomy is Carl Linnaeus and it's
his system and nature ID from 1758 10th
edition which is widely believed to
represent the beginning of this
standardized format for describing new
species and a system of nature I
Linnaeus actually described 10,000
species of organisms 6000 plants is used
primarily a botanist and 4,000 animals
if you look at some of linear systems
they're really really simple so this is
a beetle called staff align us okay and
this his species description of it is 12
words all right there's no illustration
in Sistema nature of staff align us so
if you're if you've never seen snapper -
and you come along and you see this kind
of description antennae necklace like
Electra which is the winged cases of the
beal half tail simple with two oblongs -
ellic it's kind of hard to imagine what
staffer linus looks like so this is
snapper - it's really an incredible
insects it's absolutely beautiful it's
got all of this intricate morphology
that Linnaeus's description could never
really convey yes it's kind of got
necklace like antennae and then so there
many other insects it's a liter three
cases I guess or half because they're
very short and they don't cover the the
abdomen like they do in most fields
this isn't really the tail either it's
the abdomen and
it's kind of subjective to call it
simple and yet there are two oblongs
cells at the end so Linnaeus description
doesn't really do staff aligned as
justice and since sistema nature is
published species descriptions have come
a very long way now
Linnaeus could have included
illustrations of staff align us in his
sistema nature because he did have a
microscope and it looks kind of
primitive but you would have been able
to see quite a lot with this microscope
it's widely believed that Linnaeus
didn't really use his microscope very
much even though he had one and so what
many of those descriptions are just
text-based descriptions he did
occasionally do drawings it was normally
of things that you could see with the
naked eye so what I'm going to discuss
today is how species descriptions and
specimen imaging and visualization of
these organisms in the natural world has
has evolved over the past 250 odd years
since since the schema nature I was
published and I'm going to do it with
reference to the group of deals which
are closest to my heart these are so
like firing Rovio's I've collected
studying since I was a teenager and all
of these peoples here is credible
morphological diversity of between 1 & 3
millimeters long they're absolutely tiny
but there's about 10,000 species of
these beetles to put that into context
there's about 10,000 species of birds
now there's me and about seven other
people on planet Earth you study these
Beyonc and compare that to the number of
people who study birds and this probably
represents maybe five to ten percent of
the total number of species of Cyclone
rule because out there so it's fair to
say this is a very poorly student
organisms they're ecologically probably
very important if you go to the tropical
rainforest and see sip leaf litter and
look for the beetles these are one of
the predominant groups so they're
extremely ecologically abundant and
extremely diverse morphologically and
there's thousands of species of them so
just like the nss early descriptions of
sapphire beads all's often just word
based verbal descriptions often in Latin
so this is the Reverend Kings driving a
beetle called writers from Australia and
there's a 40 word description and no
image so again if you read this
description you'd have no idea that
writers had a head like this with this
gigantic cavity inside it and if you
zoomed into the cavity you see I had
this huge spike of unknown function in
sight so just writing a few words about
a species again is not really doing an
organism like this justice and so people
appreciate it that verbal descriptions
were kind of lacking and so they started
to include they start to increase the
length of these verbal descriptions and
also start to include illustrations
sis's were afraid arriving in 1894 about
a beetle called meccanica so now we're
up to 143 words and you can read this
description it does actually give quite
a good picture of what this beetle
looked like but still not good enough
and so we're free who was actually
pretty good at drawing would start to
include
really beautiful illustrations of the
Beals they be also that you were
describing this is a study of saipan oil
fields from 1890 and I think it's one of
my favorite images at least be also it's
come from pen and ink and for the
following hundred years if you were good
at drawing you'd include images pen and
ink often stippled or pencil drawings of
of these insects or their structures in
your description so these are some
drawings of some beetles from Sri Lanka
by somebody who's obviously very good at
drawing these beetles here's another
couple I really like this is a thing
called malli cooler that lives in and
colonies in Australia seems like a
really heavily armoured tank of the
beetle it's presumably physically
attacked by the next ever the worker
ants inside the nest this is a thing
called a murat such as a blind cave
adapted one of these beetles he's got no
eyes up here support he's covered in
these hands so it moves around in
constant darkness this is one of my
favorite illustrations this is what
Claude basically from 1991 he found it's
absolutely magnificent video again from
Srilanka collar the dial that made of
this thing is and again it's believed
that it lives with hands it's got this
his neck is formed by this tiny little
sore Ridge up here and you think that
the ant come along and pick it up and
grab it by the net and carry it around
the nest and all over his body is
decorated gland numerous structures that
are involved in producing compounds that
enabled us bill to be exactly the life
of the colony
doing these drawings sometimes you can
rather than trying to do the most
accurate drawing you can it's quite
important to distill down the morphology
that you're looking at to the most
important parts that can distinguish the
species so this is the genitive P Oxus
from South America and what's really
important here there are the positions
of these structures on the head so these
are different species of the metal P
Oxus just depicting where the D where
the size and shape and relative position
of these different head structures the
same goes for this Python a plaque dying
from from South America as the shape of
this kind of inverted t-shaped area
which is important okay but not everyone
can draw and that's a real problem so
you get people like Michele ski 1855
he's I think he's probably trying his
best here but there's no way you can
recognized what any of these beetles are
from his drawings and again his species
descriptions were just a fuse few
sentences so it's really just what he
was doing was admirable but ultimately
just a waste of time and so the fact
that not everyone can draw and the fact
that you know species descriptions
verbal descriptions don't always convey
the morphology of the organisms you're
looking at means that what you really
want is a really good photograph of the
working with but the problem is being
historically that cameras weren't
powerful enough and also when you start
looking at really small organisms like
you know beetles that are a couple of
millimeters long the higher the
magnification of your camera the lower
the depth of field so for example
zooming in on this fly here you can only
see at any one one point part of the
structure being in focus now and as a
consequence for the up until maybe 15 20
years ago people generally didn't
include photographs of the species they
were describing unless they were above a
certain size threshold but this has
really changed recently with the advent
of montage imaging so in montage imaging
you get your camera with a really
powerful macro lens and you take
multiple images going through the
specimens z-axis so you start at the top
and you work through the specimen and
then using a montage algorithm you can
project all of these images together and
filter out the parts of the image which
are out of focus so you can produce this
a montage picture where all parts of the
insect are now in view and this has
really transformed species descriptions
so if you look in the taxonomic journals
now a lot of the time you'll see these
montage images and they do a really
great job of depicting the morphology
you've got from very small insects so
I'm going to show you some examples of
montage imaging from my own work so this
is a thing called this is a cyclone room
feel called du Bois Gaston I need the do
began to expand dinner and colony in the
Peruvian Amazon and it's a super cool
insect it's one of my favorite favorite
slackline reveals and so but again it's
a few millimeters long this one's five
millimeters long but with montage
imaging you can get these really
beautiful pictures of Google gasps now
this is the dorsal and the ventral
surface these are some even higher
magnification pictures I really like the
head here like looking at this thing for
long it's actually really kind of
intimidating organism so you can imagine
if you are an ant and decide to colony
in the peruvian amazon and this thing's
warmed up to you kind of fantastic so
using montage imaging you can get really
cool pictures of very small organisms
and kind of correlated with the advent
of montage imaging you can also increase
the length of your verbal species
description so this is my description of
Dubourg after here is 1752 words so
compare that to Linnaeus which is just
twelve words so I hope that like just by
reading this
tax year if you could make it to the end
then you'd have a pretty good idea to
maybe how to buy gas to look even when I
have seen the montage images this is a
genus called more for gia that I found
sitting in a drawer in the Natural
History Museum in London again it this
is from the Brazilian Amazon against a
new genus that nobody had described it
for I need it more from genius truly
after my supervisor just kind of keep
him happy but I was getting distracted
with all those people and again this is
a montage image of a 2.90 millimeter
long beetle and you could see in really
nice detail all of the structures in the
head and then the body like I found the
male and also the female of this of this
species and you see the males got this
really large eye and females got a
really reduced eye the male has full
flight wings the females got reduced
flight wings and so the male probably
flies a ret invest in flying around
locating mates with his wings and large
eyes and female and it just hangs out
ready to get to meet these are some
other montage images producing compound
microscopy of certain structures in
in more for genius of the the tax I on
the claws to zooming in through the head
to show you these Apple teams it's kind
of internal bits of scaffolding inside
the head these are the terminal segments
of the abdomen which is sexist it's
actually done morphic between males and
females and quite good diagnostic
characters but here I've also added some
drawings this is a thorax and this is
the male genitalia now the male
genitalia and insects is a crucial
factor that's often used to define
species because there's runaway sexual
selection which changes the shape of the
genitalia are much faster or evolution
in rate than the other parts of the body
and so often you'll find B or B Falls
that look alike and then you'll dissect
the genitalia and you'll find that
there's quite a few different species
there based on the morphology of this of
this structure presumably there's a kind
of lock and key mechanism there which is
involved in speciation
so there's strongly evolutionary
pressure to change the size and shape of
the male genitalia and this is reflected
in the
differences between species now
this montage imaging has become really
popular one of the best people montage
images in my mind is this dying Ziggler
Romney from hood at best and what he
does is he mounts his fancy camera on
top of a this special stand with a
microscope objective and he's taken some
images of salaf ions which I think are
the best images ever taken so for
example this is the thing called you
practice European genus and this is only
just over a millimeter long you could
see it with amazing detail almost all
the aspects of the external morphology
at this beautiful this is a zooming in
on its head and you can see again this
is you know this is a speck of dust of
the human eye but with a camera and a
microscope objective and montage energy
the whole thing comes to life this is a
vehicle Psilakis it's another nice image
by Nicola and turned upside down it's
got this kind of Santa beard of flat CTO
that bonus cheer it's really cool
this is right max it's lemon Arthur's
what another European species then looks
really beautiful image this is its head
again this is a real time deal and
you're seeing it like it exploded like
this it's absolutely fantastic
now Nicola actually started to take
images of this group of sulfides and
this group of select points are
extremely special okay because they are
ones which are only ever found inside
ant colonies they're blind they got no
ears eyes their wings have pretty much
generated the segment of the abdomen
fuse together and they're covered in
glandular structures and if you see one
of these beetles inside economy this is
one that I found the day after I got
married in Austin Texas fixing that's
your new species rather than attack miss
vo the ants will actually walk up to and
feed it liquid food mag - max Worrell
trophallaxis so this field is socially
integrated inside colonies of ants and
exists as a social parasite it's not
obviously benefiting the quality they
found the beetles have picked this that
ants will pick this beetle on carry
around the nest not only feed it but
they'll dump it in the blue galleries
where I'll pierce open an eggs and suck
out the insides this is amazing Hawk
colony parasite this is another image
from Nicola where he zoomed in on the
mouth part and you can see rather than
having a standard like the grab toriel
mandibles that most predatory beetle
said this whole head sawed turned into a
Stroup straw whereby can receive liquid
food regurgitated by the ants there are
mandibles in here this they can extend
just outside of the oral cavity tiny
amount of just just enough to pierce
open the eggs and suck out the inside
and so while Nicola was taking these
images of these of this group that
called Claridge Aaron's me and curator
of fossil insects and the American
now history found a 52 million year old
version of one of these beers in Kambei
amber from India so this is the earliest
example of this kind of lifestyle known
in in animals as formative social
parasitism and this is actually from an
amber deposit early Eocene and deposit
the marks the first appearance in the
fossil record a significant fraction of
modern ants so right at the beginning of
modern hands which we kind of set today
is in this kind of dominant group of
arthropods these beetles were wandering
inside their nests and usurping
resources and facing the penis and
unwelcome guests there was one news
outlet that referred to this this field
as the primordial moocher which I really
like so nipple that took a really cool
picture of one of these living species
this is kind of along the corners
European species and we managed to get
onto the cover of the journal Current
Biology when we published it's lots of
species which is super cool now you
might have noticed these beetles there's
many different kinds they've all got the
yam and brush-like structures on their
bodies these are called trichomes and if
you see these fields inside ant colonies
you'll see the ants wander up to this
part of the body and they'll start
licking it and these trichomes are kind
of like candle wicks which conduct
compounds from glands that are embedded
at the base of the abdomen and what
these compounds do is they behaviour
even the filly had so I also walk up to
them to find this stuff really
attractive and it overcomes the natural
aggression of the ents and causes them
to adopt they need to be off inside the
colony and so one a
line of work I'm really interested in is
exploring that exploring these trichomes
and the Clanton's glands and the
compounds that produce them and one of
the techniques that I developed which I
start to apply generally to visualizing
tonight finds is this confocal
microscopy now I can't focal microscopy
you blast your sample with a laser and
the light that bounces off is collected
through a confocal aperture which just
collects light at a specific point along
Z plane of the specimen so you can go
through the specimen through in in
sections collecting these confocal
images and then assemble them down to
what looks like a 3d projection so when
you use a confocal microscopy to
visualize the trichomes rather than just
seeing this kind of bunch of hairs
collection of hairs like you would
understand a montage image you could see
a real detail of how they how they're
formed where they're attached various
other aspects of the cuticle of these
insects and I'm not staining this
structure with anything it's just a
standard autofluorescence the shininess
of this cuticle which is a reflected
light now I'll just show you a few more
examples of using confocal microscopy
this is a thing called Janus called
himoto this is a new species again from
an ant colony in Peru
leafcutter ant colony this is an
undescribed species of me and my friends
planter named after my wife she's
awesome
and this this is some can't focal images
of different parts of the body of this
species of promoters so you can see the
head here
Hayden profile of maxillary pouch the
mandibles this is the antenna here and
with confocal microscopy you can zoom in
really close and you can see that the
male 10 Fantana mayor is this excavation
inside the female doesn't so presumably
performing some unknown role in sex
specific behaviors these are other parts
of the coiling of hemolysis is covered
in these awesome hairs and I just
started to use this confocal technique
pretty much as standard in my work on
sulfides and it's the most striking when
you're visualizing the heads of these
insects so this is cataplectic thing
from Panama you can see almost cartoon
like head which is revealed when you
blast it with the laser and under the
confocal microscope this is another cave
adapted genus called maca righties from
Europe again it's blind and it's got
these gigantic maxillary palaces you'd
probably use this to feel its way around
it around in the darkness inside caves
this is a thing called Cana Saudis again
lives in ant colonies but you can find
this genus in upstate New York don't
really know too much about its biology
but again it's got these incredible
magazine reap helps don't really know
what it's doing with them but we think
maybe is interacting with ants and
potentially being fed by the ants this
is a
genus called packer QT from Ecuador's
it's one of the earliest images I took
using the confocal microscope when I was
encouraged to submit this to one of
these digital imaging contexts and it
this picture was a finalist at the
Olympic Olympus bio escapes competition
in 2014 there's another one I send into
a competition I take these images for
other purposes and then you know it's
quite easy to email into one of these
competitions and a couple of them are
done quite well so this is tiger by fin
us thing that you find again in upstate
New York it's not obviously associated
dance this guy this one was a finalist
in the Nikon small world contest bit
showing off that okay so back to amber
know Amber's like as amazing it's this
kind of medium that's trapped in second
life millions of years and you can see
these things sitting inside a pers if
they're still alive
if you can't even suspend in our
animation these a hundred million year
old song finds in mid Cretaceous amber
from my anmar and you can see where you
do with a normal specimen you can take a
photograph and make a montage image and
reveal most of the morphology with
amazing resolution as long as you polish
the aberrant
you know it's a clean amber piece and
often and the specimens are quite dark
so this is a thing that we believe lived
inside to my colony the earliest termite
colonies I mention
million years ago and no matter how much
light you shine on this thing there's
always a part of it which is super dark
so I tried the confocal technique on the
this phantom and it worked really well
to reveal the eventual morphology of
this species and all of these
modifications to the head and the
antennae which you think are involved in
adjusting this view of the life inside
termite colonies this is some pictures
of my head it's got this really be
looking head of this scissor-like
mandibles it's super cool
they stick act thick reinforced antennae
which are probably adaptations to to
call any life and then in some cases
amber is extremely opaque so this is a
Cretaceous fridge amber again it's about
100 million years old and you can't see
through it so it's really problematic to
work with but some people in France
abuse extremely high-powered x-rays to
see through this material and you can
start to pick out insects that are
inside it and with a lot of work you can
actually reveal them with amazing
resolution so this is this x-ray
computed tomography of a
be all related to the salons that we
work with in this opaque amber from 100
million years ago and you know it's
absolutely incredible that the level of
detail that you can see there's a lot of
work involved in taking sections and
different x-ray and from different
angles accumulating these sections and
reconstructing them into the 3d beetle
like this this is a new genus and
species from David Paris and Margaret
Feyerick Field Museum in Chicago here's
another example really recently
published of a beetle which is beetle
fossil a rock fossil ok so I couldn't
actually find a image of the fossil
itself but it's a beetle that looks like
this kind of embedded like a standard
fossil in in rock and using this x-ray
computed tomography and taking these
sections through the beyond it's amazing
you can actually see all of these
external morphology and even go inside
the beyond and see aspects of the
tracheal system the digestive tract all
of this internal morphology the anatomy
of the be honest foot perfectly
preserved this is 20 to 40 million years
old and all importantly the male
genitalia are perfectly preserved and
could be reconstructed using this
technique and this field could be placed
into the evolutionary tree of the
genius it belongs to based on all the
all of the morphological attributes that
you can see using this technique which
wouldn't otherwise be visible okay so
just want to close now by discussing
insect images in the online age that we
currently fight find ourselves in now
historically it'd be difficult to study
is that many of these insects because
they found that the deposited in museums
worldwide and you either have to get a
loan of these specimens sent to you and
some museums and the tourists look
difficult about sending out loans all
you'd have to visit the museum yourself
so if you have a new species of beetle
that you've all you think you have a new
species of beetle but if you think maybe
it's closely related to this other one
you really need to see the type specimen
of that others other be your species it
was just the reference point for the
other species to compare your one to
that previously described one and know
any differences which you might justify
your decision that it's a new new
species and so taxonomy one of the kind
of rate limiting steps in in documenting
life on Earth through this process of
species descriptions if accessing all of
the specimens in these museums and
there's a big movement now in museum
museums worldwide to kind of digitized
images of these specimens to make them
available online so the entomologist in
the different parts of the world can dip
into these collections and explore that
the inventory so this is this is a
Flickr account which the Natural History
Museum in London the beetle section of
the Natural History Museum
Londyn of setup and they have all of
these historically important specimens
remember these are type specimens that
have a red label so these are the
reference specimens for this species
which you have to consult if you want to
describe a book what you think is a
closely related species just to give an
example of it's a real treasure trove of
images that they put online with so many
beautiful specimens this is a bill that
was collected by Charles Darwin in
Argentina that was only described a
couple of years ago it's a thing called
Darwin a loss the dark side described by
Stelios cat cats and menorahs and the
Natural History Museum in London have
made all of these brilliant images of it
available online and there are specimens
they're normally from Darwin but now for
us of wallets and other luminaries in
the field it's just such a historically
important collection and then making it
all available online other museums are
using novel approaches such as the
GigaPan which you can take a whole
drawer of specimens and take an
extremely high-resolution image that you
can then zoom in to individual specimens
and see see their body structures this
is still in the kind of early stages of
development
I think it's maybe quite quite expensive
but there are all of these attempts to
address this impediment caused by having
these things in drawers and cabinets and
museums and not readily available to
people who want to study them by putting
these images of them online one of the
other problems is being access to his
historical literature so often species
descriptions are buried in some book
which is out of print from 200 years ago
it's very difficult to get hold of
unless you're again associated or
working at a museum with an amazing
library and so a few years ago this
biodiversity heritage library was set up
which is scanning a huge amounts of this
literature which is no longer under
copyright and making it available online
so they're an inordinate amount of
important scientific works that can be
accessed through the biodiversity
heritage library which wouldn't
otherwise be readily available so
someone like me is not you know always
around museum if I find myself away from
the museum and I need a piece of
literature often I can find invited
iversity heritage library it's not not
everything is there but a huge amount of
stuff and it's growing you'll notice
that the biodiversity heritage library
itself has a Flickr stream and somebody
there is obviously extracting beautiful
images from all of these old
taxonomic and Natural History works
making them available online so I really
urge you to go and check out the
biodiversity heritage library Flickr
stream there's really absolutely amazing
images of historically important pieces
of literature but there
that they've been available okay and I
just want to finish by plugging my own
efforts to kind of bring the Beatles
that I work with into the digital realm
so I set up a cell a phony Facebook page
which is dedicated to the study of the
Beatles that I work with and you can
find all sorts of amazing images that me
and other people who are interested in
these fields have taken references to
literature and new studies and like a
large amount of discussion about the
biology of these fields and also
occasionally an April Fool so this is
this is a 10 legged specimen supposedly
from Malaysia that feeds on millipedes
I'll stop there and take any questions
thank you yes
so my favorite technique has gotta be
the confocal stuff because I felt like a
lot of me get back to a couple of these
as soon as I put these beetles
underneath confocal microscope I saw
them in a new way with a new a level of
detail that I'd never really encountered
them before and it was almost like
getting to know them again so it was you
know I've collected these things since I
was 16 years old and there's only a few
years ago that I started to do this and
it was it wasn't like you know a
revolution in my head and so I really
like love this technique well I couldn't
hear you other questions
Oh motion like it how they move oh yes
so that's a very interesting point I
think there's a I think that that is to
some extent and there really should be
more of an effort not to just document
the morphology of these insects but also
their behavior
okay so ultimately these specimens have
to be taken from the wild and put inside
into museums where they're dead but
before that's done if some aspects of
their behavior the way they move the way
they behave maybe what they feed on or
documented that just increases the
richness of this discipline you know
substantially so and this these are also
diagnostic characters so different
species have different behaviors and as
you say like the way they move all of
these kinds of things are different and
potentially taxonomically very
informative I think recently there was
an example of a frog which was found on
Staten Island which looked like a frog
that you find right across the East
Coast but it's got a different call and
that led some herpetologist to try and
explore whether this represented the new
species and so they sequence this DNA
and it turns out it was definitely a new
species and they wouldn't have been able
to do that had they not you know tuned
into this aspect of its biology and you
could imagine any aspect of the way
something behaves or acts could be
informative in that regard
this have you seen any efforts to use
artificial intelligence
yes yeah definitely there's all these
kind of machine learning approaches
where computers are presented with
images of this is this was there was a
group working on this at the Museum
looking at images of I think jumping
spider or some kind of spiders eyes
which are kind of diagnostic of and and
and seeing if their computer can
partition them into different groups
which you know biologists had recognized
the species so I would say yes yes there
is it's not at the stage where it's any
kind of substitute for the skill
taxonomy but yeah in the future like
like I said you know the fraction of
life on earth that we have just
described so far may be quite small and
maybe if there was some kind of
high-throughput way of documenting it
that would be fantastic but I still
think it's going to be a while for
there's any substitute for the kind of
training knife for taxonomy yeah okay
thank you very much that's great